fear onstage let's talk stage fright for  a second I mean I'm scared the whole  time I'm up there in a way most of the  time I'm on stage and I just want to be  like hidden like I don't even want to be  visible you know you know I like to  drink whisky before I get on stage I'm  like sober up there I'm just like  awkward and weird what if I walk out  there and I can't there's a possibility  that I can walk on that stage and this  could suck I could not sing I could  freak out like a panic you feel that you  can't trust your body to do the most  basic movements that you've grown up  doing and it's like vertigo that's how I  always describe the stage fright so at  first my throat used to close up on  stage you can't really breathe and you  can't really sing if you know [ __ ] that  you have to do it you just have to swap  through that fire and come out the other  end that's exactly what I needed good  [Music]